foreign
[Music]
I've actually got a thread as well I
want to finish the song hit me name a
behavior that isn't labeled as a form of
mental illness okay but you feel like it
should be okay interesting bro first one
making an insta page for your baby and
commenting as the baby oh God yeah or
for a pet or a cat
bro uh commenting as the Baby Oh Daddy
said I could wear this today yeah
my stepmom used to do that for my little
sister John to me
God me bro where like she would post
satin and then my auntie like one of my
aunties would comment like look so
beautiful and then my stepmom would
reply like thank you Auntie nimi I just
like what's good on this time
me yes dude I've not even seen that
Instagram she doesn't even know exists
I've not seen her Instagram go to school
and living her life oh my days yeah
that's tapped oh bro crazy
um next one recording yourself crying
when we were on Chloe Rose are you man
she said she said she takes pictures
daily just just cause she said she was
angry this morning she took a picture of
herself saying you and she was
crying right yeah she said mascara
everywhere she was just doing this you
know right I wrote a selfie I'm like for
our own phone why who did you send that
to
who was this for yeah yeah it was mad
yeah but I know bear girls do that but
yeah someone yeah someone replied to
that one was like bro it's when they
record themselves crying and post it
when they're not crying anymore facts
it's like facts bro you're livid it's
like when you send the voice note and
you're laughing and you have to laugh
again that's like with the quarantine
like what like by the time he's drapes
your phone you're not crying yeah what
emotion are you feeling when you're
pressing send yeah when you're pressing
record like this as soon as you've done
this and you've got what you look like
yeah I promise you're not crying so now
you have to continue crying in factors
bro speaking of I saw a thing on earlier
about some Nigerian guy just crying for
100 hours
bro I saw a post earlier and it was like
this guy is trying to do like a hundred
Iowa cryothon
after the chef thing that happened all
these Nigerians are trying to break
records what shifting so there was maybe
like last month a month and a half ago
there was a chef who cooked for 100
hours
um Guinness Book of Records taking type
thing and it was it wasn't legit
whatever and then since that day yeah
I've been seeing so many Nigerian
singers doing this and that for 100
hours you man
love Fame
that's so funny
um 300 hours of quiet or whatever 100
100 hours of straight clients will be
dry bro he was sat in a chair like this
and he's like
and this is what the time is next he's
like 11 minutes in and he's like
Jordan bro
so frustrating
um
next one given your employees Pizza
instead of a raise
my old job used to do pizza Fridays for
Joe instead of a raise yeah bro wow so
thank they used to say to thank you for
your hard work we're going to give you
an extra 15 minutes of lunch and then
we're gonna bring in dominoes everyone
was gassed
wow that makes the kids must even sit in
my car
wow these men are treated us like Lab
Rats bro
extra 15 minutes of lunch send me home
send me home I wanna do 15 minutes max
that will make me happy send me home
send me home bro that will make me gas
yeah yeah that'll make me work hard on
Monday yeah Fox give me Friday off I'm
working on Monday Pizza just used to
just make me
slumpy used to diminish my work right
but my work rate was bottom as it was it
was bottom as it was so as soon as they
gave me a bit of dominoes yeah yeah with
the the difference yeah my blood glucose
was
[Music]
I couldn't send another email bro I was
mad
I was mad jokes jokes
um right putting a filter on your baby
one million percent truth that's a
mental illness yeah I can't stand when I
see stuff like that putting a filter on
your baby I forgot that was the topic of
discussion Jesus yeah bro speaking of
babies did you know like you know when
it has um Apple has its like Photo
wrecking like facial recognition yeah so
it collates folders yeah yeah yeah or
faces and stuff yeah like you've
probably have you seen is it got one for
your nephew maybe bro it clocks them
from when they're a newborn I'll swear
uh bro it will have a folder of this one
human oh yeah it's got my nephew yeah
from newborn yeah yeah yeah to now yeah
and it still puts them in the same
folder how do you know yeah
that's crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah I can't
even recognize newborns yeah it's got
quite a few man if you more so my nephew
when he's older I suppose I didn't take
that many of him when he was a younger
yeah yeah yeah yeah I wasn't even I was
in Manny then yeah
oh bro this one doesn't make sense to me
but I bet it happens putting on sock
shoe sock shoe yeah that's that's a
crazy that's Taps that's crazy I'll be
concerned if I saw one of you managers
shoes so you have a huge one and
Barefoot yes bro yes bro so that's
homeless talk yeah yeah yeah who raised
you facts gender reveal parties I feel
the same I'm not in the mood for gender
reveal parties
um
oh this one I was deep in this one Tick
Tock just makes you believe anything is
real bro I was deep in this one the
other week saying why aren't people why
aren't the crowds speaking up this one
setting up your camera to go and pretend
to wake up and start your day oh my God
speaking about this there is one chick I
follow on Instagram right we follow each
other she does this all the time bro
she's she sets up her day
a card
I'm seeing it now but it's like it's
like how do you have the energy to
record yourself put your phone down
record yourself crossing the street
record yourself entering
this record yourself doing that and then
sit there and edit it crossing the
street record yourself sitting in a
coffee shop drinking a tea big man yeah
thinking about it's making me irate
I could never be your man yeah
oh there's no way you could we're going
somewhere and you're putting a tripod on
the street to watch yourself cross the
zebra Crossing to come back from the
zipper Crossing to pick up your camera
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no she'll
make you taste test best off and then
when you do the wrong reactions oh yes
things are that's frustrating yeah
frustrated but yeah say less claiming
pets as your babies
why You Look At Me
what was that so I was looking at
someone something else you went yeah say
we do chest in it why did you look over
here
I literally just said I was checking to
see if the camera's all right from there
you can't tell the screen's on my side
bro I was just checking
[Music]
wow
um celebrating your dog's birthday by
making him wear a hat and singing at him
oh God yeah
many videos of that so that's
final unprovoked picks that's a bit mad
that's
crazy that is actually a mental
unprovoked dick yeah bro and that's wow
yeah it's a pandemic
actually it's a pandemic bro from when
I'm getting them
they just need anyone to see it oh God
yeah scary stuff crazy scary scary stuff
so yeah order them all of them think
they're mental illness yeah um that for
some reason we're just allowed to happen
yeah because it's bad stuff that
happened like don't you think it's mad
that like only stops being weird when
society as a whole decides not weird but
until that point it's weird perfect
example go in turkey and getting a hair
transplant yeah mandem like are on Tick
Tock catalog in this yeah yeah and every
time I see it I think have you no shame
sir facts have you no shame bro yeah you
got bare black dots on your head cover
up yeah yeah I'm not doing no expose
just for some next company to make more
yeah if I'm sending if I'm going turkey
you man just think I've been hit by a
car or something fax no one knows what
went down until I'm ready to return to
suit up with a full head of hair and
don't ask me questions just know what
happened and keep it moving
yeah I've seen there's I've seen
Donnie's that do anniversary posts Jesus
and it would just be like before and
after and their heads do you think who
is this for facts facts because you're
not attracting anyone with that yeah bro
same with like um
veneers yeah with the shaved downtown
and everyone's taking pictures of the
the vampire teeth oh that's scary it
terrifies me okay I can never do that's
scary yeah I saw a um a dentist on Tick
Tock that was like you man this is not
for nears yeah this is not veneers this
is like crowns oh this is like um so
like apparently when they're doing up
in dentistry when they're doing up uh
veneers venez is supposed to be a very
very very slight shaving of the tooth
okay just to fit the cap on okay very
slight like you can't even barely tell
the difference okay but like what these
men do that are drilling it all the way
down to like a fine point that's a crown
my guy yeah all that all that Vanessa
scares me brother
and the ones that are white white uh
yeah the ones that are white white
um we're just pretended yeah yeah we're
just pretending to not gonna acknowledge
this this just is what it is mum we just
have it's not even a percent it's just
charge you see it charge
yeah
Fair that's it that's it anyway guys
anyway guys that's the episode for today
thank you for for hanging with us and uh
as always
[Music]